كيف وجدت هذا التقييم الذي قدمه الجيش
فيما يتعلق بمدى العمليات ووصفه للعمليات
في الجنوب وتحديدا في خانيونس بانها معقده
ومعقده
جدا عبد القادر عندما نتحدث عن الحرب التي
تدور في غزه هناك ثلاثه ابعاد تفرض نفسها
على كيفيه ان يقاتل الجيش الاسرائيلي اين
يهاجم اين يدافع الاماكن الفارغه نتحدث عن
ثلاثه ابعاد مهمه الطوبوغرافيا والجغرافيا
والديموغرافيا ماذا يفعل الجيش الاسرائيلي
الجيش الاسرائيلي يحاول دفع الديموغرافيا
الى جنوب القطاع وبالتالي عبر الخارطه
السخيفه التي وضعها والتي تقول عن جريدز
معينه يعني يطلب من المواطنين الخروج منها
وهذا امر صعب جدا نتحدث عن الاماكن
الفارغه وهذا امر اعدت له حماس ثلاث ابعاد
للدفاع يعني حماس اعدت او المقاومه اعدت
الاماكن الفارغه عبر الكمائن المحضره عبر
التفجيرات
عبر الاسلحه المضاده للدروع واذا توصل
الجيش او وصل الجيش الاسرائيلي كما فعل
بالع عام 2014 الى تخوم المدن هناك حرب
مختلفه اما داخل المدن فهي مختلفه تماما
فاذا هذا الامر يفرض على الجيش الاسرائيلي
ان يقاتل بطريقه تناسب المقاومه وليست ضده
من هنا هذا الوقت ثلاثه اشهر فقط لشمال
غزه ولم يتم السيطره على شمال غزه على
سبيل المثال خمسه الويه حتى الان في شمال
غزه بعد تسريح خمسه الويه في الوسط لوائين
في الجنوب تسعه الويه عبد القادر بين
المشاد المدرعات المظليين والقوات الخاصه
يضاف اليهم الدعم الجوي والدعم من
المسيرات والتكنولوجيا المتطوره هذا الامر
هذا امر صعب جدا
طيب ايضا شاهدنا من ضرب من ضمن حرب الصوره
كما تابعنا قبل قليل رئيس هيئه الاركان
مرفوقا برئيس الشباك في خان يونس وكما
تظهر الصور يدخلون ما قالوا بانه احد
الانفاق ماذا عن هذا البعد خاصه داخليا في
اسرائيل من حيث ما تحققه العمليات من
انجازات كما يقول متحدث باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي البارحه وقبل البارحه راينا
هذه الفوضى في الحكومه في حكومه الحرب
والخلاف بين المتشددين الصهاينه المتدينين
وبالتالي رئيس الاركان وكيف شكل هذه
اللجنه البسيطه فقط لمعرفه الاخطاء التي
ارتكبها الجيش الاسرائيلي للاستفاده من
الاخطاء هذا الامر ينعكس على الجيش هذه
ليست الزياره الاولى عبد القادر هذه
الزياره الثانيه لرئيس الاركان لتلك
المنطقه خاصه بعد الانزال الجوي لوجست في
غرب خانيونس هذه فقط ليقول اننا نحن
موجودون يعني انا رئيس الاركان ورئيس
الشباك موجودون في نفق والذي يعتبر بالعقل
الاسرائيلي حاليا وكانه الهاجس الاكبر
والبارحه و قبل البارحه قرات مقال بالها
اريتس يقول لا تكذبوا على على الشعب
الاسرائيلي ان هناك حل لهذه الانفاق هذه
الانفاق تعطي بعدا عميقا تحت الارض
انسيابيا للمقاومه لتخرج من مكان لا لا
ينتظره الجيش وبالتالي يعطيها هذه الحركيه
وهذه الحريه التكتيكيه والحريه العمليه
وبالتالي الانزال من المزيد من الخسائر
خاصه في جنوب القطاع ايضا شاهدنا في الصور
ايضا هذه المره من الجهه الاخرى من قبل
كتائب المقاومه تحديدا من قبل كتائب
القسام صور من الدرج وحي كذلك التفاح
والزيتون صور ايضا لعمليات تقوم بها كتائب
القسام وايضا في هذا اليوم ايضا الجيش
الاسرائلي يعلن عن مقتل نائب قائد لواء
التدريب في لواء نحال وهذا من الويه
النخبه في الجيش الاسرائيلي ايضا ماذا عن
هذه
المعطيات هو كان معد ليكون قائد الكتيبه
50 في لواء النحال قتل وقتل معه ايضا من
كتيبه ثانيه اهم بعض اهم الضباط عبد
القادر في الشمال اصبح هناك ديناميكيه
جديده الجيش الاسرائيلي سرح خمسه الويه
وبالتالي اليوم يحاول الخروج للانتقال الى
المرحله الثانيه قما كتب وقال وزير الدفاع
فاذا انت في مرحله فك الاشتباك وهذا الامر
يعتبره الاسرائيلي انه مرحله التنظيف
للسيطره هذا فك الاشتباك اعطى حريه اكثر
للمقاومه ومساحه اكثل لمقاومه كي تتحرك
وبالتالي هي لا تخوض حربا حاسمه المقاومه
هي تكمن تراقب تصور وبالتالي تنفذ من هنا
هذا القتل يعني